so we're in the badger operation center
EMF 2018 and today we're handing out the
tilde mark Delta badges
this year's badge is a GSM phone we've
got an entire phone on our back this
year we've deployed a our own GSM
network across the site
so you've got a badge running micro
poisoned with Wi-Fi GSM phone and
Bluetooth headset compatibility so you
can use it inclusive headsets to it and
make phone calls between badges we think
this is the first conference badge GSM
phone that's been deployed we've spent
the last six months two years building
this thing it's been very late and a
lobbyist been done in here at the
festival finishing off soldering
antennas flashing firmwares right and
carried off until the last minute and
we're finally handing out to attendees
today we're hoping everyone can sit and
write apps
it's a eeveelution of the badge from two
years ago till to mark pi which I had
the microphone or Wi-Fi so how did the
gsm on top you take CPU you take a Wi-Fi
chip and you take it to that phone
module and you think oh yeah we'll just
put this on the board and then you start
adding buttons and screens and sensors
and the domain processor on this badge
has 128 pins we've used all of them plus
a 16 pin port expander to interconnect
everything can get them all talking
together and there's been a lot of guys
working on code we we've we've done a
fresh port of micro Python to TI's
latest msp430 to e MCU and TI are
releasing that and our version
on top of that with the tilde board it
should be released and hopefully soon we
will get pushback two microphones
banging upholstery and yes making the
first phone call a couple of months ago
to John T was like hello I'm calling you
from a badge and we finally had the
first badge the badge phone call
yesterday morning I'm not sure because I
haven't played a lot with the software
as the PCB designer you you've got a
full menu you can find the phone number
I believe it's also tight it's tied in
to our deck or on slide deck networks so
the badges are getting a four or five
digit ID which could be full call from
the Dexter Network and it should be able
to find it in the phone app and make
phone calls and I believe we can also do
outside calls and they should incoming
I'm not sure about we got any one so I
know it's down that's what was that
though so you're bashing on the back
covering up priceless stuff in the
centuries the TI's MSP 43 4 3 2 e
processor it's the right of that we have
8 megabytes of RAM external so that
we've got a lot of extra RAM to allow
the microfiber apps and app developers
because you can write your own apps I've
got a lot of memory to play around with
this year just to the left here we have
a 1 megabyte serial flash chip that's
where all the apps are getting stored
and saved in the bottom right hand
corner is this all the Wi-Fi area the CT
3 1 2 0 which is their latest release of
their Wi-Fi chip yeah I stayed out and
over the left-hand side here we have the
1700 C GSM module the SIM card the GSM
antenna which was hand soldered we have
the speaker and we have the microphone
and this is the Bluetooth headset and
Sena the microphones have a hardware
disconnect so you can turn your
microphone off so you measure an old
hacking imagine and listening in the
processor and the SIM module of both
pops up to the speaker microphone so
we're hoping someone's going to be able
to do
from the CPU dial-up modem over over the
in band over the analog with PWM signals
and then the Telex maybe we have thanks
to seed studio who sponsored the PCBs we
have some Grove connectors which connect
to see CEOs grow sensor modules they do
a hundred different breakouts we've
stopped at that bug in round the bottom
we have some pins broken out with serial
ports and i2c and some pins that these
effort a conductive threads and wearable
stuff so showing LEDs Daniel am yard and
inductive threads down the line yard at
the game got the same pins spreading out
on headers over here and then we have
USB to plug in for Python console and a
mass storage access to the mass storage
device and on the front buttons lots and
lots of buttons so we have a t9 cube had
laid out joystick menu call nine buttons
and then we have two neopixel leds so
quite bright torch mode lots of colors
previous badge had the same top curve
but was straight across the bottom and
the screen was in in landscape and we
had the menu the a b and the joystick
buttons so yes we've grown the board and
we've still got a processor and a why
fight and we've bolted on the gsm the
processor itself has changed we had an
stm32 two years ago the Wi-Fi chip is
the it's the next generation we had the
CC 3100 last year this time we've got
the three thousand a million twenty
we've toured the battery size to allow
to hopefully allow us to cover the extra
power draw from the from the gsm modem
and the Wi-Fi run at the same time as a
bunch of sensors thrown on there for fun
we've got temperature and humidity
temperature talks under there a Hall
effect and there's a looks sensor on
front from life
when we develop in the badge we keep
everything under wraps up until the last
minute so I think the the announcement
that we've built a phone went out like
on analogue post last week a week before
the event so that people could start
writing apps and coming up with apps
ideas and also sensitive to announce at
the same time but it's surprising there
is a was an info booklet comes with a
badge which has got some snippets of
Python code to go and test them and play
around with the sensors and get you
started and there's some small soldering
projects there's a consoled an LED and
resistor and so we doing some soldering
workshops here in the town this is one
of the production panels and we've had
to visually inspect all of these we've
sat and looked at every component this
back 216 components on the back her
badge there's about 25 on the front and
we've had to look over them and find
components that have not been placed
properly or gone through the of them
misaligned or missing components and
because we're such a tight deadline
assembly sponsor HCD were unable they
didn't have the time to do the
inspection automatically so we've done
it here on site so there's two of us
have lots every board 300 panels about
2100 individual badges out of two and a
half thousand that we were in here for
so a lot which is where there's boxes
here of boards with pink dots where
we've got a fault on there 90% of them
can probably fix some of the missing
components it depends how hard it is to
solder it on some of them will be really
tiny things we can fix them if we run
low on the handing out we can start with
internal fixing these and some of them
will just leave them or fix after the
event and some were really bad dogs
going again
but yes we visually inspect them all
we've then sold to geomancer neuron
we've then been flashing the firmware on
the GSM module to enable the Bluetooth
headsets is the default firmware doesn't
enable the Bluetooth headset ability so
that still takes around a minute per
badge for two and a half thousand
minutes it's like 200 hours it's like
five days so we've had five laptops
carrying out it for a day and a half and
got through all of those fantastically
once we flashed the GSM phone where we
then have to flash our firmware onto the
msp430 to either micro pipe and port and
then it keeps it up into a bag or a
badge PCB we have a battery badge guide
screen the velcro dots are sticky vestri
on a LAN yards and hologram SIM card and
the attendees get to put it together
themselves which saves us a lot of
effort a lot of time that we haven't and
it's a lot of fun people to put them
together and and then go play the past
three patches 2014 was tilde ma e which
was two point something something
something which is the speed of light
constant 2016 badge is tilde mark hi
it was our third badge so is 3.14159 so
under the screen on tilde mark Pi is PI
to a thousand decimal places it's the
version number of the badge this year we
use irrational mathematical constants
and this year it's a tilde mark Delta
and the constant is four point six point
zero and again I've got a thousand
testing places and this year it's found
bound Delta constant
which is related to why fication
population studies and chaos theory
stuff and I can't remember the rest of
it but phytomass guys though they can
soon fill you in on that one yes lots of
number stuff done is created these boxes
make up 128 pins of the processor and
all the interconnects so these are all
all these connections go to elsewhere
I suppose I cheated I'll use my software
skills to do that I actually wrote a
program that converts MIDI files